sorry this I'm slightly a lovely
services well it's like an elaborate
setup thanks for coming in so early in
the morning at the yeah thanks for the
opportunity to speak here it's it's a
pleasure to continue the nice talks
yesterday on extended formulations so
let me just begin by recalling what was
sort of the main concept xual lemmas and
theorems that we saw yesterday and the
most important thing because we're
looking at this concept of extension
complexity which is given a polytope
what is the smallest sized linear
program or a polytope with the smallest
number of faces of which this is a
projection and this is characterized by
so we are qualitative p and we want to
understand what is the smallest polytope
that of whose p is a projection
surprisingly this is characterized by an
object which is completely well
well-defined given the polytope p and
the object is a slack matrix the slack
matrix is a matrix where you have one
column for every vertex and one row for
every face and the entry s of F comma V
is the distance of vertex V from the
face F and theorem of Vienna caucus
which is the main underlying theorem
adder on all the results in extension
complexity is that the extension
complexity of a polytope P is exactly
equal to the non-negative rank of this
slack matrix associated with the
polytope so just so we are on the same
page the non negative rank of a matrix
so you are given of the slack matrix the
non negative rank of the matrix is the
smallest R such that the matrix admits a
factorization like this like a long
skinny matrix and a thin matrix like so
where s is equal to u times V and
typically if you just minimize R such
that s is equal to u times you get the
rank of the matrix here we enforce an
additional condition that the matrices U
and V are
I have non-negative so and that gives us
the non negative rank and clearly non
negative and is more than the rank okay
and and the ANA caucus theorem shows
that extension complexity of the
polytope is the same as a non negative
and so this clear software okay so so
one thing that Thomas alluded to
yesterday at the end and which which is
interesting is that if you look at the
slack matrix we've defined it with one
column for every vertex and one row for
every phase you could you know extend it
further by having by having a vertic
column for every point X in the polytope
so now it's an infinite matrix and
having one row for every hyperplane or
every inequality that is true for the
polytope every hyperplane which doesn't
cut the polytope so now it's an infinite
matrix but but that doesn't change the
non-negative AK of the matrix it's just
a different object but it's it sort of
it will be useful to think of in this
terms so and it was useful even in the
lower bounds which Thomas showed
yesterday in that we use hyper planes
which are not necessarily the faces of
the polytope
okay so even we as an example will
restrict our attention to the
correlation polytope so what's the
correlation polytope
it's the convex hull of X X transpose
where X is a boolean vector okay and why
is this poly tope interesting the reason
it's very useful is that if you want to
optimize any quadratic function over the
boolean hypercube that's the same as
optimizing a linear function or the
correlation poly tope and a lot of
combinatorial optimization problems can
be posed as optimizing a quadratic
function or the hypercube so in
particular if you look at the max cut
problem we are given a graph G the max
cut problem is you're just trying to
maximize the number of edges cut and if
you if LG is the laplacian of the graph
then maximizing the number of edges cut
is essentially maximizing this quadratic
form X transpose LG x over the boolean
hypercube and that's to say essentially
the same as maximizing a certain linear
function or the correlation polytope so
a lot of np-hard combinatorial
optimization problems can be solved if
you could express correlation polytope
compactly and so it's a very useful
important polytope to study so another
thing is I wanted to mention is
yesterday we we went faster than we
expected so I have more time than we
expected right so so please ask
questions stop me whenever I'm not clear
you have a lot more time and you know we
might end up stopping early okay so so
now you know we have this correlation
pollito so I think it's a good idea to
actually go back and talk about look at
the slack matrix and non-negative rank
in terms of the problem that we are
solving which is the max cut problem
instead of the polytope so it's it's the
same thing but it's just somehow I find
it the terminology might be useful to
think about these things so if we're
trying to solve this problem maxcut
which is this maximization problem and
that's the reason we looked at this
correlation polytope which is a convex
hull of XX transpose which are the
solutions to that problem so now if you
look at the slack matrix right so what
are the vertices the vertices are
nothing but these are nothing but
integer solutions to the problem
these are the integer solutions for the
problem that we are studying so in this
case if it's a maxcut problem with just
say one column for every integer
solution and for the faces well in
general we have or every face of the
correlation polytope but really the
faces that we care about the the
functions that we want to optimize or
this polytope which are just really the
graphs the maxcut graphs so the faces
really correspond to instances of the
problem
in this case if it's maxcut is a bunch
of graphs and if it said some of the
prom it's all possible instances so you
could define this slack matrix not for a
polytope but for a problem where you
sort of have integer solutions and on as
your columns and your rows are all
possible instances again it's an
infinite matrix and entry is just the
upper bound that you want to certify on
that instance so the entry like for
instance in max cut what would you what
is this
s of G comma X maybe you want to certify
an upper bound of C so let's say it C or
let's say you want to get an alpha
approximation so you want to certify an
upper bound of alpha times op opt of G
minus X transpose L sub G X right so
this is a
if you look at this function you what
you really want to do is to certify
non-negativity of that function
it's a went a little bit ahead of myself
so you know if you essentially now that
you have this idea that the rows are
integer solutions the columns are
instances any row of the matrix is just
a function on solutions a real valued
function on solutions right clearly just
just because it's a column vector it's a
vector with that many entries so it's a
non-negative function on solutions why
the faces are instances yeah so actually
not yet not every face is in instance
but I should be more precise would say
every instance is a face in the sense
that right so what are we trying to do
we're trying to solve maxcut so we wrote
this optimization or the correlation
polytope right so and what is it what
does it mean to certify the value of the
max cut being smaller than let's say C
it's just to certify that C minus L sub
G comma X is greater than or equal to 0
for all X in the correlation polytope
yeah this is true this is what we're
trying to certify so this is a
hyperplane that we want the that
separate you know that's on one side of
the correlation polytope so that's an
inequality so that's a so so therefore
essentially every row is an instance or
actually the rows the only rows that we
care about our instances of maxcut
because if you're trying to solve only
max occur and not care about the
correlation polytope the only rows of
all of the matrix a tree care about our
instances of max cut and every the only
columns we care about are the integer
solutions and the entry suppose you want
to get an alpha approximation is just
alpha times the optimum on that graph
minus the value of the cut X on the
graph G
so that so that's the function which is
this row suppose I look at the row
corresponding to a graph G this row is
actually equal to this yeah
so essentially we're going yeah and so
you can define a slack matrix for a
problem and things like that so you yeah
but the construction is essentially the
same and then you could talk about
extension complexity of a problem saying
what is the extension complexity of
getting an alpha approximation for
maxcut that's equal to the non-negative
rank of this matrix right so actually
alpha some fixed number more than one
right so so here alpha there's no this
in some sense alpha is some fixed number
more than one suppose you want to
understand what is the extension
complexity of getting a 1.1 or 1 you had
1 over 1.1 approximation for max cut
then you're trying to certify that the
value of max cut on a graph G is not 1
you said I tried said if an upper bound
on the value of Max Kurt
yes so the question was this kind of
instance versus solution way of looking
at slack matrix is it only for the
correlation pollito no it's essentially
for every problem every for every
problem I mean why we prom where
extension complexity sort of applies
extensible complexity we doesn't apply
to problem or is not very cleanly
applicable to some problems like for
instance if you look at independent set
problem on a graph the extension
complexity it's a little bit tricky to
define extension of Plex T there because
in terms of writing lp's extension
complexity is sort of lower bounds
against LPS that whose constraints do
not depend on the instance so if you
write an LP for max cut where the
constraints of the linear program do not
depend on the graph just like what we're
doing here the correlation polytope is
independent of the graph lower bound
section complex here like that and
that's mostly what we can do for many
problems so it's interesting but if you
look at a problem like independent set
it makes sense to add a constraint for
every edge or for 3sat if you look at a
class you want to add a constraint for
every class and therefore it does
extension come it's a bit tricky to
define excitation complexity carefully
there but yes yes it would work for
weighted independent set where you fix
the edges so you allow the person to and
in fact there is a nice lower bound by
Swensen and which every actually are
actually they did prove an extension of
X lower bound for in the following model
you I'll show you a graph you can look
at the edges and write a constraint
write arbitrary constraints but then I
will reveal the weights on the vertices
with respect to which you want to solve
minimum vertex cover and then the
extension complex this aggregate I think
it was it exponentially lower bar yeah
they get them definitely superpolynomial
lower bound for this in this word but
but it's it's a little bit subtle to
define it yeah yes where as well as just
writing down the set itself you also
write down like for all pairs of
vertices are both of these in a set yes
so yes yes yeah so you can sort of those
independent set if for instance you can
write Maxima if maximum independent set
as an linear function over the
correlation pollito you can do it and
therefore but when we trying but
essentially lower bounds for extension
complexity make a lot more sense when
there's no reason the linear program has
to differ depend on the instance and it
becomes more and more trickier as it you
know as you add constraints that depend
on the instance okay so in questions
okay so let's
so okay so now with this viewpoint if
you look at what's happening over here
in the slack matrix right every row of
this is again a function of solutions
and non-negative function or solutions
if the row VI is non-negative functional
solutions and what we are trying to do
is we have a small number of these
functions for there are rows there are
different functions and what we're
trying to do is to express the function
that we want to certify is non-negative
as a non-negative combination of these
so let me be I'm going to write it up so
so basically using this the way we
described it every linear program for
maxcut or for of size R or a I could
even say every extension curve every
extended formulation of correlation
polytope corresponds to a family of
functions on the hypercube okay if you
have a linear program of with our
constraints there are are different
functions on the hypercube and
and so if you think of it in terms of
proof system you want to think of these
as your axioms of your proof system
these are the axioms that the linear
program knows to be true or non-negative
and the theorem is that the LP you know
let's say if you are talking about
approximation let's say the LP yields an
alpha approximation if and only if for
every graph if you look at the slack
function for that graph what is the
slack function for that graph it's again
a function on solutions which is you
know alpha times opt of G minus X
transpose the value of the cut this
function is a boolean function is a
function of the hyper cube this should
be a non-negative combination of the
family f so it should belong to the cone
f
alternately the linear program certifies
you know that this function is
non-negative by writing it as a
non-negative combination of the axioms
it knows okay and you know the most
obvious example is what happens for
let's say the D round sherilee Adams for
dear Aunt Sally Adams the family of
functions is just non negative D haunt
us
we're hunter D hunter is a function that
depends on Leon D coordinates okay so
these are functions F such that F
depends on X sub s where s is at most D
okay if you look at non negative D
hunters this is a family of functions
and if you use this family of functions
the lp you get is the Charolais atom
selfie so you could write equivalent ly
define fairly Adams LP in terms of in
terms of these family of functions and
so the so the reason we are able to
prove our bounds in extant formulation
it's sort of this very simple set up
where in some sense when you're writing
down an LP you are trying to pick the
axioms we're trying to pick a small
number of functions because the number
of functions is the size of the LP and
once you pick the small number of
functions you are supposed to be able to
write every slack function as a
non-negative combination of that and so
so that's the reason we are able to
prove lower bound so that's sort of what
happens so we'll say oh if you only pick
our functions you are not in there are
graphs which you can't write as
combination and therefore okay so sort
of the same thing is true with SDP
extension complexity I just stated so if
you want an SDP form ax occurred if you
want to talk about SDP extension
complexity form ax cut the SDP of size R
form ax cut corresponds to having a
vector space of functions like I've
written down the basis so there's a
vector space of R squared functions okay
and such that SDP yields an alpha
approximation if and only if the slack
can be expressed as sum of squares of
func functions from that vector space so
in particular in case of if you look at
the example which is the degree D SOS
the vector space of functions is this is
just span of all this is lower degree
polynomials degree D polynomials
and what the SDP does it's stripe is
essentially it get a given the slack
function it tries to express it as sum
of squares of functions from this vector
space which is sum of squares of low
degree polynomials or in case of if it's
a general vector space sum of squares of
functions from that vector space so this
was some of this lot of it was already
covered yesterday by Hamza okay so now
so now we want to pull lower bounds for
extended formulations but before we try
to get to general extent formulations
there's an interesting subclass of
extended formulations that we want to
look at which is symmetric extended
formulations so what is symmetric extend
formulations here see that you see that
the correlation polytope has a lot of
symmetries in particular I I can permute
the N coordinates of X the correlation
polytope stays the same alternately the
the computational problem maxcut has a
lot of symmetries in the sense that
permitting the vertices of a graph gives
you another instance of machs card right
so you might hope that the linear
program that you write for maxcut is
also respects the symmetries so like at
a very rough level you might say
permuting the vertices
society them here I mean permitting the
nodes of the graph the nodes not the
vertices of the polytope permitting the
nodes of the graph
I just permute the constraints in your
LP
this is a natural notion of symmetry in
the sense that the feasible region stays
the same if you permute D the nodes of
the graph but of course this is a fairly
you know the way I've defined it some
fairly rough definition of what symmetry
is that it's a little bit more subtle to
define symmetry correctly for this there
are made slightly there are few
different definitions there are a couple
of different definitions one definition
is to say so you have the permutation
group acting on the correlation polytope
okay for every permutation acts on the
correlation pollito what you would want
to do is you'd want a lifting map a lift
map l that sort of commutes with the
permutation commute to the action so you
say there's a permutation group acting
on the correlation polytope you want a
corresponding action on the upper poly
tope hi and then what what you'd want is
that the action commutes oops
sorry
so so so while my Apple pen keeps
charging right here so it should take a
minute maybe but so what so what so I
won't maybe I shouldn't try to define
symmetry to precisely but essentially
what you want is this lifting map to
satisfy this property that if I lift
Sigma of X that should be the same as in
the lift and acting the steps but you
know if you like if this is not very
precise you could just stick to this
definition which is fairly intuitive and
which is sort of true for all the
positives that we know about for
instance if you think about Charolais
address for the second annika symmetric
LP relaxation in case of Sara Lee Adams
relaxation for this correlation pollito
what would what would permitting the
vertices permitting permitting 1 through
n the original variables right so that
would commute pairs xixj to some other
pair and so it would permit all the
constraints of the earthly of the linear
program so so the face is the you get to
permit the faces okay so see if this is
true then you could ask what does it
mean for the non-negative factorization
so now we want to lower bounds for just
symmetric extended formulations for
symmetric linear programs for
correlation Porto what does it mean for
the non-negative factorization
okay yeah good so but before we get
there let's see what's known for
symmetric accent formulations the first
results by Anna Kirk is was for
symmetric accent formulations yanogapa
showed that every symmetric extended
formulation for the matching polytope or
the tsp polytope requires exponential
size this is already very nice and in
fact you might suspect that since you
know a problem like tsp so symmetric or
probably matching is very symmetric
there is no use in using an asymmetric
relaxation for a symmetric problem right
it you might suspect that a symmetric
relax is there no stronger than
symmetric relaxations for whenever the
polytope is so nicely symmetric but that
that's turns out to be false and this is
a very surprising result by cable
pressure coefficient is that if you take
look at the polytope of log n partial
matrix it has polynomial size a
symmetric lift but no polynomial size
symmetric lifts just a partial matching
with log n edges less than ya know
images and in fact ice so going back to
yesterday's talk it could be that the
extended formulation that we get by
dynamic programming for knapsack is in a
symmetric extended formulation which is
smaller than every symmetric Excel
formulation for knapsack
so asymmetry does have and you can make
in dynamic programs it's clear very
clear that you you would want to assume
it asymmetry you'd want to fix one
variable and you want to fix the order
in which we'll do it but this what it
shows
but the polytope is symmetric right so
even over here the the the all maximum
all matching instances are not symmetric
but the polytope itself is so the
knapsack oh yes sorry yes yes so yeah at
the AI right
yeah actually knapsack is not symmetric
so this doesn't even apply there yes
okay so if my pen is charged now let me
see okay so now you know we had this
equivalence penelope's and as you know
family of functions SD peas and vector
space of functions let's see what
happens here if I write symmetric LP
here every symmetric LP is corresponds
to an invariant family of functions and
every symmetric SDP responds to vector
space with an invariant basis of
functions so what is an invariant family
so invariant is essentially the family
stays the same you should permute so
what that means is if you take a
function from the family and then the
entire orbit under permuting the inputs
also is inside the family so if you take
any function in the family and you take
any permutation Sigma is a permutation
if i look at f composed with sigma this
is a new function this function should
also be in the family so that's what it
means for it to be invariant so in like
funny sense this family of all degree
for family of all d hunters is invariant
because you take a d in d hunter and
permute the variables you get a
different D hunter
yeah not every function is invariant on
its own but the entire family stays the
same when you apply this this as it
turns out is a very strong restriction
on the family and so she could ask when
can an invariant family be small like we
are looking we're interest in small
linear programs are smaller like extent
formulations how when can extend
formulation be symmetric information be
small
meaning when can invariant family be
small you know let's try it out say
imagine you had a function suppose you
had f of X is equal to let's say some
majority on some n over two coordinates
yeah if you include this function in the
family then you would have to include
every permutation of that which really
which will mean that you have to include
every majority and then over every
subset of n over two bits which means
you'll have n choose n over two
different functions in your family if F
belongs to the family then already it
implies that the size of the family is
super large like n choose n over two
okay so a very few functions that you
can I actually include and still you
know have a small size for so for
instance one obvious candidate is you
could include f of X is equal to x1 and
x2 right all permutations of this will
give you n squared different functions
and that's fine right so in particular
you could include F is any D hanta this
will give you after permutation at most
n choose D different functions this is
one candidate okay is there anything
else that we can include
yes so symmetric functions so like you
could include f of X is equal to
summation X I for instance this is a
function and of course it is completely
it depends on every variable but it's
still so every symmetric function is
fine
[Music]
yes yes yes yeah that's right so addy
hunter on its own will generate n2z
different functions so there are
interesting functions in the orbit of f
which is sort of acceptable because we
have thinking of as LP of size roughly n
to Z but if you size exactly into Z then
you need you can have only one such
function so depending on n variables
that's a metric it's a function
depending on the Sun yes that's a good
point so so since we are our boolean
hypercube if you have any symmetric
function it's a function of summation X
I any symmetric function is essentially
H of summation X I and you could do
something slightly more complicated you
could mix the two basically you can have
f of X to be a function of some subset
of D coordinates and the sum of all the
coordinates if you look at such a
function this will general so generate n
choose D
and as it turns out this is essentially
all you can do right if you take a any
boolean function whose sorry any
function the hypercube whose orbit is at
most n choose K it's actually a function
of the form a H of X sub J comma
summation X I where J is at most K
coordinates and summation X I is the sum
it only depends on the sum and the end K
coordinates yes
don't vote for me
all right yeah
right so why can't we use and minus D
who does right yes yeah yeah it's right
the issue is really when we permit the
variables you
you also pump you could generate new
functions that way for instance if you
had a crazy function on n minus D
variables when you permute the variables
inside that function itself will
generate new so your function and n
minus D variables will also have to be
symmetric somehow right basically
because if you take yeah that makes
sense so if you if for instance if you
had some function some a symmetric
function on n minus D variables H is an
a symmetric function on
in minus D variables then if you permute
all the variables of X even though you
use it you're using the same set of n
minus D variables you will still
generate new functions that way so it's
a very strong symmetry to say that the
orbit is small and of all but one
variable is a function of this type
because he knew the sum offer every bit
and then if you knew that bit then you
know yeah okay so
Oh
I used to you can only get D factorial
different things there right so the
thing is really yes yes yeah yeah yeah
right so actually I should say okay
small like case I can over to or
something much smaller so we're looking
at relaxations of size n to the K
roughly and we're looking at we're
asking we're looking at think of case by
much smaller in over to let's say n over
time right so so then it's so so why is
this theorem true
well this theorem is follows from
theorem and group theory which is
essentially that if you look at the
permutation group and you look at any
large subgroup of the permutation group
so if you have a subgroup H of the
permutation group such that H s i--'s
more than n factorial divided by n
choose D so it's basically a really
large subgroup then what could h be it
could be for instance all permutations
that fix D variables right that's what
you'd expect you would expect that H is
all permutations are fixed D variables
it it's essentially something like that
in the sense that H contains all even
permutations that fix D variables so
there's a subgroup of H which contain
which is all even permutations of that
fixed D variables so you use that on the
automata facin group of the function f
and you go
uterus theorem sorry I rushed through
that proof I wasn't planning on doing
that proof he's neither straight but
yeah okay so yeah okay so so now so now
that we have this very powerful hammer
that if you take any bull any function
the only function that you can pick in a
symmetric extend formulation are things
like this that depend on a hunter and
summation X I now you will prove that
through a lower bound for symmetric
extend formations okay our starting
point is going to be an integral T gap
for sherilee atoms the reason being we
want to prove lower bound or against
functions that look like hunters right
there just a little bit more complicated
than hunter s so let's start with some
lower bound for holders so what does it
mean to be a lower bound for hunters so
let's fix some funk function which
Charolais atoms cannot certify
non-negativity off and this is one of
the very simple functions that you can
use so here's the function if you look
at it pick an odd number m okay and you
look at this function I claim that this
function is non-negative over the hyper
cube because summation X I since M is M
since M is odd mm over two is a fraction
it's not an integer so therefore
summation X I will never be equal to M
over two it will be off from M or two by
at least a half
so therefore summation X I minus M or 2
whole squared is at least 1/4 always so
this is a function and which is
non-negative over the hyper cube and
this comes from essentially knapsack
problem basically you can take any other
problem that you like for instance you
could take max cut max pick a
integrality gap instance for max cut for
cheryl items and that gives you a
function which which is of this form in
meaning it cannot be expressed as a
non-negative combination of non-negative
Hondas
so now we want to prove a lower bound
against this more general class of
functions so it's going to be a little
bit of cheating so
MND so let's so here actually D can be
as simple as large as M over 2
you need up to M or two rounds to
certify this but for the proof you could
think of it as you want to prove it into
the D lower bound and the pick and
integrity gap instance before D round
surely Adams maybe it's a max cut
instance which means you might have like
a tenday vertices or something and then
you run the run the proof okay so now we
want to prove lower bound for this
general class of functions so let's fix
n to be two times M ok so we'll prove
lower bound for correlation quality up
on n vertices so so what do we want to
prove we want to prove that V of X is
not in the cone
of functions of the form H of X sub J
comma summation X I things that are
juntas and some summation X i4j smaller
than D or some right J smaller than D
basically basically we want to show that
V of X is not in the corner of these
functions for small J and that will
imply that the lower bound on the
symmetric sin formation so suppose not
suppose V is in the cone right sophie is
actually in the cone so so let's say fee
of X is equal to sum of a bunch of
functions of this type
does it make so I'm assuming for
contradiction fees in the coal generated
by functions of this type so fee can be
written as non-negative combination of
functions of this type so lambda sub H
are non-negative numbers all right okay
so I I did a slight she I mean I didn't
give you all the details here so first
thing I didn't tell you is what is
relation how is M and n related to n is
2 m so fee was a function M bits so I'm
right you saying fees a function n bits
so how is that so I'm thinking fee as a
function so it's a function on n bits
but it's the same as applying this on
the first n over two of them right so
know where to
just since n it's 2m fee takes only M
inputs you use the first half of your
string as inputs to your problem okay
but this identity is still over X one
trick that this is an identity over 0 1
to the N because we are talking about
functions on 0 1 to the N this is a
function 0 well to the onion ok so now
the little trick is we just want to
somehow eliminate this summation X I
because once if we could eliminate
summation X I then we will say fees are
no combination of filters which would be
a contradiction and the little trick is
you just apply substitution here so
imagine setting X you know the second
half of your x1 through xn as the
complement of the first half
so you set X m plus 1 to be equal to x1
minus x1 X M plus 2 is equal to 1 minus
X 2 xn is equal to 1 minus X M just the
second half is the complement of the
first half you just fix you just
substitute that here the reason to do
that is if I do that summation X I is
always M if I take the string and its
complement the sum of all the bits is
always M so once I do that substitution
what is what happens to this identity I
get fee of x1 through XM is actually
some lambda H H of X sub J time comma M
like a fixed number now this is a hunter
there because a related summation X I
this is a hunter so I have expressed my
original function fee as a non-negative
combination of contrast which is a
contradiction because fee was an
integral to GAAP instance for Shirley
Addams
[Music]
that part of where the integral
decapping why is that particular
inequality oh oh right sorry it's not
right so it's not very important what
the scenic form of the inequality is all
I am saying is pick an integral to GAAP
instance on M variables like a graph on
M variables okay now look at the now
fixed n is equal to 2m now introduced so
that gives um other vertices which are
sort of isolated just because the same
function so guys in if it's a graph wave
the graph and then you ICN isolate
vertices and then and then its identity
is still true on that on that 2 + 2 m
size graph this is um you know that this
area is true what that implies this ayat
is true for any fixing of the dummy bits
so I'm as well fix the dummy bits to the
complement of the of the original bits
and see what happens to this identity it
becomes an identity of this form where
we have written the original hard
instance for sherry Adams as a continent
non-negative combination of hunters
exactly yes yeah so yes yeah so this is
the objective function that's hard to
guess exactly yeah you take it you can
take an integrating app instance for
Shelley Adams and that implies a lower
bound for symmetric external formulation
of this correlation polytope
as you can see the proof is a little bit
of you know it's just a little bit of
trickery of you know having an
integrator gap instance of shale Adams
gets you almost all the way to the end
because it tells you it's not a
combination of hunters then you have to
deal with summation X I then use a
little trick to deal with it and this is
indeed the case that because of this
lemma symmetric external formulations
are essentially surely atoms but if it
will be more precise I think theta body
is probably sort of the correct term
that essentially capture symmetric
extent formulas in the following sense
they capture every symmetric extended
formulation is subsumed by surely atoms
already if you take any symmetric
extended formulation of size n to the D
is no the polytope is essentially
subsumed by Cheryl diadem's polytope of
deerhounds in the sense that in every
direction the face of the shari adam
says inside the Polito
so strictly better on every instance
that's not much the thing that we really
sort of use is that the underlying
solution space is zero one two then is a
product space so we can talk about
hunters and things like that if you for
instance talk about the matching
polytope or the TSP poly tope the
solution space is the space of all
matchings so now we are dealing with
functions on matchings and so it's a
little bit more tricky to define hunters
and so on but the essentially the key
lemma is true and essentially the
following fact is true that surely atoms
or the theta body actually captures any
symmetric external formulation and the
proof is essentially using the same
technique just that so in this case the
analysis is works very smoothly whether
it's in 0 1 to the N or or matchings or
TSP tours in what we'll see next which
is the symmetric extent formulations we
use Fourier analysis on 0 1 to the N and
so on and you could hope that those
techniques you could have hoped that
those techniques give you a lower bound
for matching polytope also but it's once
you'll want to deal with functions on
matchings the foreigners gets really
hairy and it doesn't work out about to
be known how to make it work but yeah so
so the yeah this the the function that
we deal with that functions on solutions
so it's the solution space using
symmetric functions
Oh for the matching polytope basically
because of the skill my everything is
really simple if I tell you a function
has a small orbit you can essentially
tell me what the function looks like or
0 1 to the n so similarly true for the
matching polytope but in a general
CIMMYT relaxation we won't have this
fractional you all know yeah I think
it's a good time to stop will in the
next lecture we'll talk about a
symmetric extended formations
[Applause]
those from the collection during their
collections social trust
[Applause]